ich denke jeder von euch sol.de rtl2
serie hilf mir jungen leute verzweifelt
kennen weil es nicht hier deren
wikipedia-eintrag hilf mir jung pleite
verzweifelt ist eine scripted reality
fernsehsendung des deutschen
fernsehsenders rtl 2 sendung wird seit
dem 4
november 2013 täglich außer samstags und
sonntags im nachmittagsprogramm des
senders ausgestrahlt die folgen werden
größtenteils in köln und berlin gedreht
hilfe für junge leute verzweifelt ist
also eine tief aus kriftel reality serie
des tv senders rtl 2 und atv sachen ja
in dem zeitalter der digitalisierung
nicht mehr so krass laufen haben die
natürlich auch einen youtube kanal für
diese serie erstellt hat sich diesen
kanal vor einiger zeit an entdeckt habe
habe ich mir eine video angeschaut und
darauf auch in einem youtube video von
mir reagiert indem ein typ ein
35-jähriger typ meint er sei ein sechs
jahre altes mädchen okay
vielfalt ja jetzt wisst ihr also was in
dieser serie ab geht doch in einem video
habe ich nicht nur auf die folge hilft
media geht sondern ich habe auch meine
community also euch meine zuschauer
gefragt ob ich versuche sollen bei einer
folge mitzuspielen das ganze bei ihren
job und ich habe das meer spaßeshalber
gemeint doch als ich dann zwei tage
später wieder die kommentare geschaut
habe habe ich dort einen kommentar von
rtl2 gefunden in dem kommentar zitieren
sie als allererstes eine video stellen
und zwei minuten 6/10
kann ich mir auch mal mitspielen bei
high tech trat lustig also hl2 kann ich
mal ganz auftritt bei euch haben also
auch diese video stelle bezieht sich
rtl2 in diesem kommentar aber ich würde
sagen wir gehen den kommentar einfach
mal durch also sie schreibt hey luca
einfach so eine voll verzweifeltes halo
kann schon gar keinen bock auf mich
eigentlich wir sind dein lieblings
sender rtl2 mein absolut lieblingsländer
bewerbung ist angenommen
[Musik]
natürlich ist das das heißt die sagen
damit ich darf in einer folge hilf mir
mitspielen du hast die wahl zwischen
folgenden themen die betrügerische
bademeisterin eine parabel auf das leben
und dass ehrlichkeit am längsten wert
ihr seid rtl2 schöner wenn eine folge
hilft wir den sinn hat eine parabel auf
das leben zu zeigen dass ehrlichkeit am
längsten wert war gut
rtl was ist denn die zweite option lust
große landschulheimen das ist also der
kommentar den wirklich der offizielle
rtl2 youtube kanal unter meinem action
video zu einer folge hilft mir
geschrieben hat und ich meine leute
geredet haben von rtl 2
die haben beispielsweise so serien wie
berlin tag & nacht köln 50667 die
geissens frauentausch einfach das beste
überhaupt und nebenfrauen tauschen
mitten im leben die ganzes können
berlin tag & nacht wird weiß ich noch
alles haben sie natürlich auch noch hilf
mir ich zeige euch mal ein paar
ausschnitte aus ein paar folgen von
hilfe um jeden preis mein kind muss
berühmt werden 320 euro für die
tanzschule sag mal geht's noch stalker
alarm verliebt in den chef
ich weiß schon scheiße so ohne geld war
tote hose mein freund will nicht mit mir
schlafen und spaß ist die testo box
ich nehme ja es ist richtig schön da
sieht man glücklich was das für folgen
sind und auch was das für verzweifelte
schauspieler sind
ich bin nicht helfe sollten auf jeden
fall habe ich mir das war gegangen
gemacht halo cavallo wirklich mal so auf
sparerfolge hilfe mit spielen würdest
wie komme ich denn jetzt den kontakt mit
rtl2 weil die werden bestimmt nicht noch
mal unter mein video gehen und schauen
ob ich den darauf den kommentar
geantwortet habe ich bin ja erst mal auf
die website von rtl2 gegangen habe dort
dieses impressums und kontaktformular
gefunden und in diesem kontakt formular
steht soweit e-mail-adresse
zuschauerredaktion rtl2 punkt.de und
dann habe ich erst mal eine e mail an
rtl2 geschrieben betreffe
meine teilnahme bei hilf mir sehr
geehrte damen und herren eigentlich viel
zu höflich einstieg für sondern hielt
mein name ist nicht betreiber des
deutschen youtube kanal konnte ich mich
erst mal kurz ein bisschen vorstellen
falls jemand liest er jetzt nicht den
kommentar unter meinem video da
geschrieben hat in einer meiner letzten
videos habe ich auf eine folge ihrer
serie hilft mir reagiert doch das halt
erstmal und sozusagen worum es überhaupt
die daran habe ich spaß deshalb auf eine
community gefragt ob ich jetzt mal
probieren soll auch in einer folge hilfe
zu spielen daraufhin haben die betreiber
des youtube kanals hilft wir folgenden
kommentar unter mein video gepostet
und dann komme ich halt zu meinem
eigentlichen anliegen und zwar ich bitte
um erklärung war diese wirklich eine
einladung in einer neuen folge von hilf
mir als schauspieler mitzuarbeiten ich
hätte definitiv bob neue liebe grüße
euer lukas klasse mail lukas natürlich
keinen plan hat so wirklich diese e-mail
zuschauerredaktion rtl.de
dieses thema betreut sage ich mal wenn
man eine frage hat zu einer bestimmten
serie habe ich noch einen tweet gepostet
oder werte l2-cache rtl2 meinte diesen
kommentar unter meinem hilfen ihr video
ernst hätte bockmann mitzuspielen
hahahaha habe euch auch eine mail
geschrieben bereits 0 xd doppelpunkt de
also meine mails und tricksen recht
einsame spitze
zu guter letzt habe ich dann auch noch
unter die neueste hilf mir wieso oder
auf youtube geschrieben check mal euren
twitter account juli wird gerade von
meiner mutter eingeladen schokolade zu
probieren was ist mit mir
wo war das ganze thema ist sie zu ende
zu bringen ich finde der fordert etwa 20
minuten ich wollte das nicht eine sehr
sehr sehr kurz halten es geht einfach
nur darum dass ich eine reaction die
schraube ist ausgesprochen ich habe auf
meinen kanal eine reaction zu einer rtl2
folge von hilf mir hochgeladen und habe
in diesem video meine community getragen
glaube ich das mal probieren soll in
einer folge hilfe mitzuspielen da auch
wenn da der tv sender rtl 2 mein video
mit diesem kommentar kommentiert mit dem
inhalt die bewerbung angenommen ich sage
natürlich erstmal zu hause gedacht wir
was meine schauspiel-karriere habt ihr
zum durchbruch allerdings habe ich nun
rtl 2 eine mail geschrieben ich habe an
sie getwittert und ich habe ihr neuestes
video auf dem hilft mir kanal
kommentierte was das denn mit dem
kommentar auf sich hat und das jetzt
ernst gemeint ist oder ob sie das auch
noch spaß gemeint haben bei real top
leute ich hab da eigentlich gar keinen
bock drauf aber es wäre echt lustig wenn
ist eine gastrolle in einer folge hätte
und dann vielleicht mal durchs bild
laufen würde kurz was sagen würde oder
so ich bin auf jeden fall gespannt auf
rtl2 sich nochmal melden gilt bei mir
und sie auf meinen trieb bitten wir um
eine e-mail beantworten werden
allerdings heute morgen wollte ich auf
eine neue folge von hilf mir reagieren
ich hab mir gedacht dass ich mir
entweder auf die folge fällt um jeden
preis mein kind muss berühmt werden
reagiere oder auf stalker alarm verliebt
in den chef ihr habt hier um eine
abstimmung und können sagen auf welche
der beiden folgen ich morgen reagieren
soll
oder wenn ihr wollt dass sich auf eine
komplett andere folge hilft mir reagiere
dann schreibt es gerne unten in die
kommentare spend ruhig rum auch was sich
da reagieren soll bei der erste reaktion
von paar tage auf diese folge wo dieser
35-jährige typ meinte er sein ein sechs
jahre altes mädchen mega krass gut bei
euch an hat mich auf die aufrufe
bekommen die sache nur viele leute
meinen und hey es gibt schon viele
andere kanäle die auf hilfe mehr
reagieren ja aber ich find reaction sind
bei jedem anders und von daher finde ich
eigentlich nicht schlimm wenn andere
leute darauf reagieren stimmt also auf
jeden fall über die abstimmung hier oben
ab auf welche folge ich morgen um
15 auf meinen kanal reagieren soll oder
schreibt mir eure folge in die
kommentare
die ihr am bescheuerten findet rtl2
falls ihr das ihr seht kommentiert doch
mal gerne ein video
dann können wir alles besprechen mit
meiner schauspielkarriere
[Musik]